are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
[Music]
[Music]
gentlemen we're live fantastic okay
folks episode number 151 with
paul manafort paul manafort if you don't
know the name
uh probably in 2016 you couldn't turn on
the tv newspaper magazine uh anything if
you turn on social media you would have
seen his face all over the place
non-stop
uh and there was many different reasons
for that we'll talk about many of the
reasons today we kind of want to hear
her from himself as well background uh
party campaign consultant chaired the
trump presidential campaign from june to
august of 2016. he served as an advisor
for presidential campaigns of
republicans gerald ford ronald reagan
george h.w bush and bob dole and on top
of that in 1980 he co-founded
the washington dc base lobbying firm
black men fort and stone along with
principals charles r black and roger
stone joined by peter g kelly in 1984 so
we got a lot of stuff to cover with that
being said thank you so much for being a
guest on the podcast good to be here and
if i if i uh ask you correctly this is
the first time you're doing a long form
like this you've not done a two hour one
not yet it's gonna feel like five
minutes so uh it for for the audience
that doesn't know because you've been
away from it for a few years meaning not
that you've been away from it you've not
been the the controversy has not been at
its peak the last 12 24 36 months
but if people that know your name the
average person that knows your name
if they're from the republican side
they think you were framed they think
they uh put you in jail they think they
came after you simply because you were
associating with trump
and they think that that durham
investigation that came out saying the
fact that hillary clinton clinton's
dossier was all fake targeting trying to
get you guys to not get reelected a form
of revenge on the other side if you
watch snl
if you watch rachel maddow anderson
cooper don lemon any of these other guys
they would say you had a
connection to russia and putin and
collusion and trump and all of that and
all that's true and that's actually not
why you went away but for the audience
that doesn't know maybe share with us a
little bit about your background and how
it came to the controversies in 2016.
sure i uh
i guess i'd start with i went to
georgetown university graduated from the
law center there as well
practiced law for a few years but then
you know got always was interested in
politics i got involved in republican
politics very young my father was mayor
of my hometown
it was a blue-collar town very
democratic town he was a republican uh
first one in his family
uh became a republican because he
disagreed with what fdr did in yalta uh
my father fought in the world war ii and
was incensed that uh
that uh
roosevelt gave away uh central central
europe and uh eastern europe uh and
thought we fought for those freedoms why
could he just how could he just give
that to a communist country uh that was
impactful on him
and in talking to him as i was growing
up it became impactful on me uh
first campaigns i got really involved in
were uh when i was at georgetown i got
involved with nixon's reelection
campaign uh and then
ford's campaign then
began to be actively involved at the
national level really in ford's campaign
uh served as part of the team that uh
that ran it uh working with uh jim baker
who was his first campaign uh but he and
i became very good friends during that
campaign
yeah he's a good man he's a very good
man and uh i talk about in the book i
talk some of uh
uh the stories about those early years
when he was learning uh
chief of staffer jerry ford was a very
uh
green behind the years uh uh policy guy
named uh dick cheney
uh it's so
uh really early on in my career with
that campaign i got to know a number of
people personally and
that who became figures in the
republican party for the next 40 years
uh during the uh
you know after
the
76 campaign got involved in governor
reagan's campaign for president again
was part of the senior team and
after he was elected
roger stone charlie black and i started
a political consulting firm which really
became a lobbying for a government
affairs firm as well
and that really
began to change the model or in the
you know before 1980 most of the
government affairs work was done by law
firms
people were hired and law firms were
hired to deal with specific issues that
made legislative issues or regulatory
issues
uh and we decided to create a different
model we were interested in
international affairs we were interested
in
in
government affairs and so
we thought it was a natural as
grassroots politics was just beginning
and we were on the cutting edge of some
of that to bring some of the campaign
skills into uh
into washington government affairs and
the only republican firm at that time
was a company called timmins and company
bill timmins was legislative director
for uh for nixon in the white house but
he had a very different model his model
was to have
10 or 12
corporate clients
and uh and to only represent that group
we saw ourselves as a
much different concept uh and uh in the
firm group became probably one of the
most powerful firms in the washington
scene during the reagan and bush years
during that time we expanded our war
beyond just corporate 500 or to include
a number of countries representing a
number of countries always i should add
uh with u.s foreign policy interests at
heart and always in concert with the
white house notwithstanding what uh
rachel maddow and people like that have
said over the last few years and in fact
if you look at our clients you will see
that we were always involved on in areas
where the foreign policy issues were the
uh where the issues uh affecting those
countries for example in angola
uh we represented jonathan
who was a freedom fighter
for unita and active in uh
in dealing with
[Music]
they're trying to end the cuban con
concentrated in the soviet uh dominated
angola government
um
and uh
we certainly got involved in the congo
got involved in
guinea and we had a big african practice
uh working with reagan foreign policy
and bush foreign policy uh objectives in
africa
again in the course of the last five
years a lot of this has been distorted
and we'll talk about this some i'm sure
today it's in my book as well
where
the
woke left for one of a better term
decided that they were just going to
declare
that i was pro-russian
pro-putin
and uh
never with any facts i mean because i
represented a an oligarch
in russia that became tantamount to
anything and everything for my whole
career and uh and he was an oligarch
that we were not doing things in russia
on
um although he was concerned with
bringing some changes to russia as well
and i get into that in the book
so it means over the course of of the
last 20 years i got involved in ukraine
uh i mean i thought it was ukraine was a
very important country
uh the soviet well the russians were
trying to uh
to
force ukraine to not become part of
europe i thought ukraine should be a
part of your uh elected a government
that uh
was from eastern ukraine it was you
thought ukraine should be part of europe
absolutely 100 and in fact my whole time
there and this is all but your client
didn't want that though no that's not
true that's not true and in fact if you
look at his his presidency
uh you will see that the ch
the changes that were made in ukraine
yeah uh over those three and a half
years of his presidency we changed the
economic system the legal system and the
uh uh the regulatory system working with
the european union directly and i was
working with european union directly
again are you talking about yanukovych
yeah about yanakovich and this this has
been part of the 1314
he was elected president in 2010 right
and immediately the first thing he did
was go to brussels
and commit himself to working with
brussels to become part of ukraine
when historically all previous new
incoming presidents went to moscow first
uh it was very controversial very
controversial not going to moscow he
understood what he was doing he
understood the symbolism of it and so
did the europeans and so did the
americans and they started working with
him
um and and
the
if you look at and this is all public
information but it's not convenient
facts
if you look at what he did during those
three and a half years he prepared
ukraine to become part of europe he even
said that while he wasn't committed to
make ukraine part of nato yet because
that was too controversial of his
decision inside inside ukraine he left
that question open
and it was only when
uh putin realized that the negotiations
for the trade agreement which was the
predecessor for the associate the
political association agreement was
about to be signed
that putin's threatened yanukovych
publicly again this is all public
information
and said to said the other coach that if
you sign this trade agreement i will
immediately shut down all trade with
ukraine which was approximately 70 of
ukraine's trade and the trade agreement
that we had negotiated with uh said that
publicly oh yeah
it threatened because the decision was
made sudden there's celebration
everyone's outside kids are waiting
college students are waiting they're
about to go out there and party hard you
know the scene you've seen it and all of
a sudden boom well we're not going to do
it but but there's a lot more to the
story and that that's all again public
information
uh yeah when when putin made that threat
publicly because because he wanted
ukraine to be part of a trade
association that he was creating he
putin
unicorn said no
um and you know which said
we actually asked uh beaudrock the
president of the european union
for
a
subsidy to help ukraine bridge
the time frame when it was become going
to sign the association agreement
because the way this document read if
you look at it
the the early advantages in the first
three to four years were favorable to
european companies because ukraine was
basically taking down its barriers and
its trade uh its trade barriers and its
in its own uh
tariffs uh and allowing it to be a free
trade part of a foreign association
and if
russia was going to shut 70 percent of
their trade down
of the country now
all of us trade with with ukraine but 70
of the of the foreign trade ukraine
couldn't have survived that
and so it needed the subsidy the
european said no
uh and yanukovych then said look i can't
sign this and have my country shut down
if you're not willing to help me but i'm
not saying i'm not going to sign it i've
got to work out this problem because two
you know a week before whatever it was
when he made this final statement
ukraine ukraine learned that it was
going to have its markets shut down
that's when everything fell apart that's
when everything exploded did he did he
share that with his people this is this
is public information
but what i'm trying to say is in that
moment when he said i can't
did he share that with his people that
70 of our commerce that goes through
russia we're gonna lose this was all
public yes absolutely 100 percent that
that same debt
that's in you go back and you look uh at
the international news you look at what
putin threatened you look at the
ukrainian news of the impact of what
that would be you look at what was being
said to the uh to the european uh union
members
it was this is all public information so
let me ask you what's your opinion on
putin on the way he threatened so in
that situation say it's 2013 and
yankovic is sitting there and he's kind
of like uh i'm not saying his name could
be
just sitting there and he's saying
hey listen i'd love to do this i'm
joining you but if i do
our number one guy that's doing business
with us we're gonna lose 70 percent
in that moment when putin was bullying
yanukovych what was your opinion about
putin in that moment well my food has
always been the same going before that
moment after that he's a thug what
you're seeing today
in ukraine was what those who were
paying attention to ukraine 20 years ago
saw
you saw the writing on the wall with
putin 120 years ago that you like did
you are you saying that you kind of
predicted what's happening today yeah i
i what i'm saying yes i mean
can i predict that uh
that the
rubble that's happened no i would never
have thought
that putin would have
leveled the country but did i was i
aware was or was anybody aware of
putin's desire for ukraine yes putin
always felt and again
we in the in the west
things are right out there and
that we don't pay attention to because
we don't want them to be uh
true but putin has always said he
thought ukraine should never have been
given its independence by khrushchev and
khrushchev i mean the story on ukraine's
independence it was part of the soviet
union but it was an integral part of
greater russia khrushchev when he was
the general secretary in the 50s was
from ukraine he was ukrainian and so as
a gift on their independence day he gave
them their independence
never thinking that the soviet union was
going to collapse never thinking that it
made it was a distinction without a
difference
um and you know putin was totally
against that i mean he wasn't involved
back then but he thought that was one of
the two biggest mistakes in the history
of the soviet union the other being
gorbachev's uh working with with reagan
and
bush to break up the soviet union so
he's always been a historical ukraine is
part of russia not ukraine is is an
independent country with russian
heritage have you ever met putin no
no no um
and
so so
what
putin was doing
and with putting the squeeze on was
because he finally realized that which
was serious even though mind you
changing the legal structure changing
the economic structure changing the
regulatory structure it's a massive
amount of work and ukraine went through
that for the first three years of
yanukovych's presidency with great
detail working with the european union
they called the the committee on
enlargement uh which is the body that
from the ec that deals with potential
new countries and i personally was
working with stephan fellay who was the
commissioner of the of the commission of
the foreign enlargement and we worked
through
thousands of issues
uh all towards the end of getting the
trade agreement signed and then getting
the uh
the political it's called the
association agreement side
that was the key work during
yanukovych's time
where things went badly
for yanukovich with the west was about a
year and a half in
when he had his opponent former prime
minister timoshenko arrested
and he had her arrested for corruption
corruption which her president when she
was prime minister viktor yashenko was
president victor yushenko accused
timochenko of the same corruption but it
was part of his base so he couldn't go
after it
later in life he did he was very public
about how she uh she committed uh crimes
in dealing with ukrainian interests on
russian gas
coming into the country
but when yanukovych
you know
had her arrested the west went crazy
uh because she was the darling of
albright the darling of clinton
uh even though she was a corrupt prime
minister it was if you were for people
that don't know she would be the modern
aoc would you put her like that who how
would you say her personality how she
was
well i i know i wouldn't call her aoc i
mean
the the uh
she was a typical
soviet politician
uh but she was good-looking
she understood how to work the media
tyler
and uh and she uh
she sold herself to merkel and albright
and clinton
um
as
the hope of the west the reality was she
was the putin candidate again in 2010.
you know which wasn't
again one of the the major misnomers
they didn't want yanukovych
uh yeah they and the reason they wanted
her is because
the corruption that she committed that
she was arrested for
was when she went to russia
to negotiate
the the agreement with the between
russia and
ukraine for the gas pipeline
what happens until the north stream
pipeline with germany all of the russian
gas to europe came through a pipeline
through ukraine it was very important to
ukraine's economic lifeblood
and uh this is her
uh yeah it's her before she changed her
hairstyle
can i ask you a very
let me let me say one thing here and
then i'm gonna i'm gonna go to you you
know what's tough for me for for the
average person who's not on the inside
to believe this
is if yanukovych was against putin
and putin wasn't happy about yanukovych
then why did he few months later when he
was in exile come and protect him and
bring him to russia to provide safety to
them that's a very
i agree with that that's i was opposed
to yanukovych you know
there was a
a
you know some people call it a coup some
people call it a revolution that was
geared towards yanukovych that
probably was not not
indigenously grown by itself i'll leave
it at that for now but i mean i'm from
iran okay so i remember when i'm a
revolution baby october of 1978 right so
three months after that the shah's in
exile right and romani's in france he
comes from
france
to iran and he was in exile for 15 years
i think he was in exile twice home
anyone they eventually was hiding in
france but it's kind of like iraq to
come and say hey shaw come and stay here
in iraq and we'll give you protection
it's very weird
for you to say that he's not against
putin but putin provides that protection
because putin saw the destabilizing
effect
again
you you have to understand something
else about ukraine and which putin is
learning now
uh
eastern ukraine is ukraine's two
countries
there's eastern ukraine which is a
russian ethnic base and there's western
ukraine which is uh he's more european
hungarian polish
um
and
yanukovych was very popular in eastern
ukraine even near the end of his time
why because he was protecting russian
culture russian heritage russian
language but not joining russia
uh and and and what putin didn't
understand when he invaded ukraine
expected everybody to be running into
the streets in the east to
see him as the conquering hero
was that the ukrainian people of russian
ethnicity
uh
do cherish their freedom their their
history their language their their
religion this is a big part of the fight
in ukraine is is the orthodox russian
orthodox versus the ukrainian orthodox
religion it's very political but and the
eastern ukraine ukrainians are russian
orthodox
um
but they treasure all of that and the
united kingdom which was their protector
but what they treasure just as much if
not more
is their freedom
in eastern ukraine i did over 150 polls
in ukraine i understand the whole
country very well i had uh
in all of my polls so you know i would
be testing to to understand the the
dynamics and the between the the
conflicts in the country and of course
the russian the eastern versus western
part of ukraine conflicts
no poll with those
were any of the russian ethnic
ukrainians in eastern ukraine ever more
than four percent saying they wanted to
be part of russia and not part of
ukraine
they cherished their ukrainian freedom
because they knew the difference between
freedom under
soviet slash russia versus what they had
in ukraine
[Music]
and so there was no desire to become
part of that and putin is seeing that
now in its ugliest uh uh manifestations
with the
uh the people fighting you know you know
they've got a citizen militia that's
that's defeating the russian army right
now and and it's just as strong in the
eastern part as it was
yeah is it is in the western part of the
country yanukovych was the hero to them
putin to the eastern to the well to yes
prince definitely to the east which was
his base but also
not to the elites um
in the west but to the elites in the
east and the another ugly secret that
people don't like to talk about
is some of the biggest promoters you
could be again also let me back in one
second the economics of ukraine
the west east is where the wealth of
ukraine was because that's where the
industry is that's where the uh yeah the
gases and
and
the west part of ukraine is the bread
basket which is an important part but
it's it's not the engine of the
ukrainian economy
the oligarchs
in the eastern part which are most were
most of the important oligarchs of my
time there
they
saw the importance of going becoming
part of europe not staying a part of
russia
and it's again if you think about it
it's logical
they were
sort of the the bastard child uh with
with the oligarchs of russia uh they
didn't have the power they didn't have
the political support they didn't have
any of that and so and and they were
always at risk to the russian model and
which was also the ukrainian model of
how you a business and who owns a
business and in those times and in
russia still it's you have the power you
have the business so if you have a
change in leadership the new leadership
they don't
try and buy up your interest they come
to you and they say here's the shares
sign them over to me
it's it's a corrupt you know system
and
the eastern ukrainian oligarchs
saw the protection of the west in their
of their business interest if they were
part of a real market economy and were
part of a real democratic framework uh
political system which being part of
europe would have been for ukraine so
they were in the fort and this was the
base the economic base of yanukovych's
support as well so yanukovych one of the
first things that i talked to him about
before i agreed to to help him was his
commitment to becoming partner of europe
to him he saw the value of being
an independent president of a free
ukraine that was going to be the biggest
country in europe
lots of natural resources lots of
ukraine offers a lot to the world
absolutely and it's so but they have a
lot of controversy they go back to
lineage with nazi with hitler there's
their history is not the most well
that's the western part of ukraine not
the eastern part um but
but again from yanakovic's standpoint
yeah and that would mean frankly he
would say that at times why do you
overlook the blemishes in the my eastern
ukraine western ukrainian
opponents and and
over exaggerate the blemishes on the
eastern ukraines there's too much to go
into doing lazalinsky what do you think
about how zelinski is handling
everything
he's been brilliant
i mean i mean
zielinski was an actor
who
played the role of president on a
popular television program and people
would joke to him to say you ought to be
run for president all these other guys
are doing a terrible job
and he did and he won and
i never expected this out of him but
he's risen to the moment he understands
his symbolic importance to democracy to
ukraine and he's been brilliant and uh
and
you ever met him uh once but not in an
important way i mean yeah and
and like ronald reagan and really like
donald trump he understood how you use
the media to promote
and and what he's doing
you know one of the criticisms i always
had about the west is their
sort of
superficial support for ukraine being a
part of europe there's a lot of history
as to why they didn't want ukraine to be
a part of europe but they could never
say that
um
and you look at the support that the
eastern
east western europe was giving to
ukraine until it became unconscionable
not to give it lethal aid
and
you see exactly what i'm talking about
excuse me
but what zielinski has done
is he recognizes the the sort of
duplicity of the leadership of europe
and so he's speaking to these
legislatures the brilliant part of that
move is not that he's speaking to the
politicians he's speaking to the people
in those countries that those
legislators represent and he's forcing
those legislatures
to actually give him the lethal aid that
he needs
because he's creating the political
groundswell in their countries that's
his brilliance and he's also calling on
artists to create
the ground smile that you're talking
about
because he understands
that the european political community
and the washington political community
by the way is is not you know there were
a lot of reasons why they were
comfortable with the sort of data that
existed between
russia and ukraine uh you know with
ukraine being western oriented a
democracy not under russian control but
not outside of russian hegemony they
they accepted that merkel you know who i
think was a terrible leader for the for
western democracies uh you know she was
she was a patsy for putin do you think
merkel was a terrible leader and a patsy
for food how do you say that because i
think that she basically empowered putin
to do what putin is doing today
with north stream too which totally
undercut ukraine i mean the life
economic lifeblood of ukraine was that
pipeline
and because it flows from russia through
ukraine
all european gas went through there
um and
she understood the importance of it but
she signed the north stream two deal
which was going to choke off
ukraine
create a vassal state that's what putin
was trying to do was one have the
europeans dependent on the pipeline that
he controlled and to
kill ukrainian at the same time
by taking it away i mean putin has been
playing these moves for a long time the
west they're not stupid they've
understood it but they were comfortable
in the little this little that mentality
yanukovych upset all of that
because yanukovych said
i want the eastern ukraine leadership
wants to be part of of europe the
western ukraine leadership wants to be
part of europe so now we're truly united
as a country wanting to be part of
europe
one of the reasons i got involved with
yanakovic after i was convinced he uh
would support ukraine coming to uh uh
into europe
it was the the my feeling that ukraine
was the equivalent of nixon going to
china only nixon could open up china
because he came from the anti-communist
right-wing part of the republican party
and so he brought republicans who would
have been the natural opposition
into the fold
same thing was true as far as i was
concerned in ukraine
eastern ukraine what needed
a leader from eastern ukraine that could
help them accept becoming part of europe
uh minimizing the the the
the conflicts that could exist
when eushanka when the orange revolution
happened in 2004 i wasn't involved i got
involved you know after that uh and i
got involved frankly because
it's a little bit of what i was talking
about earlier
eushanka who was the western candidate
and who won
was
renationalizing companies of eastern
ukrainian businessmen and then selling
them below bargain prices to his
oligarchs so the transition was
happening and an oligarch uh who you
know had a uh a steel company uh it was
hired that had hired uh aitkin gump a
democrat firm and they asked me to help
him as well
and that's how i got involved in ukraine
um
but
what happened
in 2004 as a result of this
renationalization rep and then
privatization game that was going on
is
that the eastern european eastern
ukrainians decided it was time
that they really got actively involved
in becoming part of europe because
to be in the current environment that
ukraine had
it was not really getting the
protections of
free market principles of of of
uh
some of the corruption issues uh and so
they got all in yeah kovich convinced me
that he would be supportive of it and
and i got involved um
so
if you look at from that moment forward
what where ukraine is today how did
yanukovych find you
through this oligarch through this older
garden so did you work with the oligarch
in russia first or did you well this is
a ukrainian old guard ukrainian because
you also work with a oligarch in russia
what happened was
i worked for oleg derapasco right it was
it was an oligarch and who is he exactly
he's the aluminum king he's number two
largest aluminum uh company in the world
russia he's from russia yeah he's a
russian oligarch
he had plants
all over the world i mean natural
resources that were needed for aluminum
and things like that
and uh and he hired me to help him
actually
involve get involved in elections in
this country what year was that what
year was that this was probably 2005
yeah it was too hard so that's way
before so you
and he was in russia at the time when
you were working with him he was in
russia at the time but my work for him
was not in russia my work for him was in
the countries in africa and in
ukraine where he had plans and where uh
he needed help
two types of help number one
protecting his interests by having
me help build a live lobbying strategy
public affairs strategy firm because a
lot of these countries were either
dictatorships where it's culture or
former parts of the soviet union uh in
in the stand countries like kazakhstan
turkish medicine ukraine
and
so i was helping to build a
and running election swarm in some of
the democratic countries in in africa
like guinea um
and
in the course of that he said you want
to get involved in ukraine because
they're talking about nationalizing one
of my plants down there in the in this
pro-western government that's supposed
to be against this kind of stuff and so
i went down and i looked and i started
getting involved that's how i interacted
with aiken gum
and that's how i then was introduced to
renateof who was the ukrainian oligarch
who was having his countries
nationalized as well
and uh
and it was because of that
that as i was helping him akhmatov said
to me
would you ever think of running helping
us with an election here in the united
in ukraine i said well it's going to
depend i mean
who am i going to help you with what's
it going to be all about and he said
look take a poll see what i mean you
know our interest now because i've
gotten to know the some of the political
interests figure out what we need to do
that's what i did and
in the party of regents which was the
party of the eastern ukrainians
and that had been discredited in the
2004 elections
what i saw in that first poll was that
the party wasn't really discredited as
much as demoralized america there was
support for the party in eastern ukraine
it was a regional support i mean you
just like you have red states and blue
states uh here in the united states in
ukraine you had
uh uh russian you know ethnic states uh
old bliss as they call them and and
western oriented obelisk it was you know
the western part of the country
uh and so it became a red blue kind of
uh breakdown
in
the the
typical to what you see here in the
united states they didn't talk to each
other they talked over each other they
didn't listen to each other but what i
found
was that the eastern part think as i
said a few minutes ago they did not want
they they did not want to be part of
russia they needed they wanted to
protect their interests the party of
regents protected their interests
because it was from the it was from the
eastern part yanukovych was the governor
of donetsk before he ran for president
uh doughnuts being the one of the the
biggest oblast in the in the east
and uh they saw him
as a loser
and there was some controversy whether
he tried to steal the election some
people say shanko tried i wasn't
involved i never got involved in that
issue
i made it a point that whatever a
campaign i was going to be involved in
we were going to have an electric
election integrity component and work
with all of the international
organizations to bring them in to watch
the elections and ballot security and
every one of the elections i was a part
of there was a major component of it
where i actually had a part of my staff
dealing directly with the european union
on election integrity and facilitating
the international observers coming in to
watch the elections in all of the
potential places that were corrupt
you know what's crazy as i'm listening
to paul
this guy's a ukraine expert
i mean you know don't judge a book by
its cover you know there's a lot of
people especially on the left they're
like oh he's just corrupt you know
russian
you know pawn like this guy's been
dealing with ukrainian politics for two
decades and he's breaking it all down
i'm trying to follow what's going on
ukrainian politics how many americans
literally know as much about ukrainian
politics as you no
zero like you're an expert on this i'm
the expert on it the expert on ukrainian
politics including with the u.s state
department as well by the way that's
what i'm saying here i feel like he
could be utilized not scrutinized uh
that he's been by the media but but it
doesn't it's not convenient i mean there
are to quote al gore inconvenient truths
the inconvenient truth is that they
would have to acknowledge
that it isn't black and white right yeah
you know one of the biggest problems for
yanakovich and the reason i think he
fled was something that i was came down
hard and adam right there he was corrupt
but they were all corrupt yeah i mean
for if you just say you can't be free
and cool but you have to be for x
x was just as corrupt zalensky is also
no i know zelinski's a different model
i mean there's a
zielinski represents
an emergence of ukraine from
the shadows of the ukrainian of of of
soviet uh influence i mean he's a new
style politician he doesn't come out of
politics he hasn't he hasn't been
corrupted on the way up now there are
people who say well he's owned by one of
the oligarchs uh who is corrupt but it's
almost by necessity right like he was
doing his thing whatever but now when
putin invades he's got no other option
when did you realize yanukovych was
corrupt well i mean
i i didn't know how corrupt till it was
over
um
and but it was going to show up in my
polls i mean there was corruption that
was going on and
barista was one of the corrupt companies
that that i was
wailing against that you you've got to
you know bring the light onto all of
this stuff and uh
and and barisswa
was managed by corrupt
yanukovych people who were partners of
hunter blood
so let me let me ask you while you're in
it
and you're going through this
and you're having you know you're saying
150 polls i've been there you know two
decades all this stuff
what do you know on the inside of the
involvement of biden's what they were
doing hunter and his father well
did i know that he was knows iran in
ukrainian business yes
did i know what he was doing no
did i care no why because i was working
with the obama administration
the obama administration the obama
embassy in kiev
needed my help i mean you know one of
obama's
first major
international victories was getting all
of the uh nuclear fission uh waste
product out of ukraine
uh there was a big conference on you
know collecting all of the the from the
various soviet countries that had
nuclear by-product uh there was that
were weapon-grade you know
nuclear product
obama in the west was trying to put it
all under control of the west
and
russia was totally against it
and
yanukovych in his first year as
president
sat down with the viking with the obama
administration and got the deal done
with the huge you know
objections being uh
expressed by putin and i think was
medvedev at the time
um
uh in russia
and uh
and so
i was working with the embassy on a
regular basis whenever the embassy in in
kiev us embassy and kiev had a problem
with for us business companies or or
for something that was going on
politically that they disagreed with
what was happening they'd reach out to
me
and i would and i would work as an
ombudsman if you will with them and
every one of them ambassadors um
you know if
mundane things is getting jeff piott's
dog into the country because he couldn't
get it into the country it's a big deal
to him it was
to uh to over working with them to make
sure the international observers got to
go to every district to watch election
results as they wanted to
um and so by the way this you're saying
this is under the obama administration
the obama mission yeah who was secretary
of state at that time
okay yeah who who reset the russian u.s
relationship right the button that she
couldn't even press correctly uh to
reset the relationship i mean
you know so when you hear rachel maddow
and people thought i was working with
this russian oligarch in 2005 six and
seven because that's when i worked with
him uh who's very cl who's very close
to to uh
to putin
now
but wasn't then and he wasn't part of it
then
um
it's no different than when obama became
president and i was working you know
obama set the reset with russia not paul
manafort um and what he reset
was
the the time the political relationship
between the two countries
my oligarch that i was working with was
at a different time but now the stink of
putin today
and the image of of of putin today is
being held up as what i was dealing with
and for with deripaska back in 2000 it's
totally different
but there's no distinction between putin
and
u.s attitudes in russia
from 2004
uh with with bush to
2009 and 10 resetting it with obama and
clinton uh to
2013 when putin went to war against
ukraine and the west and even then obama
blinked and let putin get away with it
which is why you're saying with crimea
and what he tried to do with these quote
independent eastern uh
uh zones of uh of influence in ukraine
and don't ask in the hearts
yeah so
it's just all blurred together
and there's no distinction between you
could have been for
medvedev when he was president
the u.s was looking at him as
potentially being the end of putin now
in in the because they viewed medvedev
as a bureaucrat and somebody who didn't
come out of the kgb
uh and so his this is one term of
president
uh that putin actually put him in on
they were hoping he would become
a two-term president and putin would
fade into history and if that had
happened i think the world would be very
different today
but they didn't do anything to help
medvedev
and they and
at that time i was trying to promote
uh you know
western uh foreign policy
because i saw the difference between
medvedev and putin and how that could
impact the world but also more
importantly for my vision at that time
ukraine wasn't met with the the the
individual who
uh obama got caught with a hot mic isn't
that the conversation so what was that
so
what are your thoughts on what happened
there well i mean that's another part of
the hypocrisy of the attacks against me
i mean here uh
you know
obama gets caught on the hot mic saying
to medvedev tell vlad i can be a lot
more flexible in dealing with him after
my election because this was done
this was done i think in the fall of
2012.
um
and uh
and obama meant it he wanted to be more
flexible and broaden relationships
partially i think because he recognized
that putin was not going to let medvedev
have a second term and he was going to
have to deal with uh you know he's
saying to the current president medvedev
tell the prime minister i'm going to be
more flexible what is that what kind of
signal does that send
well medvedev you're still the lackey
and putin you're still the power even
though medvedev you're the president
yeah and the russians know how putin in
particular knows how to read these
signals
um and and so guess what happens in 2013
2013 you have the cu you have the uh
revolt in russia
in ukraine and uh at 2014 crimea gets
invaded because
obama putin doesn't fear obama they you
know and then he puts who does putin
fear
well
right now he probably fears zilinski he
thinks so i mean he respects him a lot
more he'll never say that
but you know he's just you know he's
with him with a citizen militia has just
defeated the russians
okay but that's that's that's misleading
because it's not a citizen militia just
by itself they're backed and armed to
the teeth by the united states
government no they sent them
15 billion in federal and military aid
we are now switching from soviet era
weapons to nato weapons we're also
providing providing them intelligence so
it's not just a citizen well they are
completely backed in a proxy war by the
united states well no i mean
you've blended it all together they that
what they did the first month
where they blunted the the so the
russian invasion in kiev was done with
the remnants of the lethal aid that
trump gave them
obama wasn't given a lethal in the
future there's there's again they're
still backed by the state whether it's
trump of course or or biden they're
still backed by the united states well
barely now now biden has gotten much
more active he's the the two the
secretary of state
and the minister of defense is just
going to go into
uh ukraine because he's got to
why though because because it's one it's
the right thing to do yes but but i i
wonder how this ends up
because even back in 2016 in the obama
doctrine obama was interviewed by uh
david goldberg of the atlantic and said
and said that the united states has no
interest in ukraine because russia can
always exert dominance over there that
there's no interest to us okay so
again it's it may be the right thing to
do but why is it the right thing for us
to do okay we're continually providing
aid we're continually providing
intelligence and day after day we get
more and more involved in this proxy war
with the second strongest nuclear power
in the world okay you've said a bunch of
things that you need to break down here
because number one you said correctly
what obama's policy was which was it's
not our it's not our backyard
okay i happen to think 44 million people
who want to be part of the west
deserve to be given the tools they need
to become a part of the west
i also happen to believe that putin
showed his teeth in 2014 when he invaded
crimea and we didn't do a thing we
barely registered objection no sanctions
of syria's nature were put on there were
sanctions but they were not significant
and what happened as a result of that
putin then moved into eastern ukraine
in 2014.
that got stopped pretty much because of
ukrainians not because of the west uh in
in pressure that the europeans were
starting to feel now and it was an
election year coming up
uh in the united states
then so so now putin sees all of
that trump becomes president and obama
refuses to give any lethal aid
any lethal aid which
people here don't follow but the people
over there do right and they understood
the significance of that putin
understood the significance of it so did
the ukrainians and so how did the
ukrainians get their weapons in 2016
through
mercenaries through you know the arms
you know the underground arms operation
and and that's how they were able to get
some but not enough
then trump gets elected president
what does trump do for almost first
things in first year in office he gives
lethal aid now putin is seeing a change
in the leadership of the country
you know this pro-putin president new
president donald trump is given lethal
aid and has said don't mess with with
ukraine
putin pays attention to that
biden gets elected president
biden brings in the same foreign policy
team that was dealing with this area
under under obama new titles new chairs
but it's the same team
putin understands what that mean first
thing biden does is he makes the united
states energy dependent again by
shutting down new production second
thing he does is he removes the
sanctions that trump put on on north
stream too
which were serious sanctions absolutely
and what what does that putin see there
okay i got the i got the obama foreign
policy team in place now i got
biden helping me you know and build my
my my energy
position in the world uh and because the
us is going to be becoming a net exp
importer
the the extra flow of of
gas is coming from russia through third
parties which means he's making billions
of dollars more to fund his war machine
in moscow so he sees all of that and
then he says
you know to to the west don't bring
anybody into nato what were his
conditions for peace and not not having
him invade ukraine he wanted the
commitment that ukraine would be not be
part of nato well ukraine said they were
not prepared to be part of they were
never going to be a part of that so that
wasn't an issue but then he said and i
want all nato country borders with
military western military nato troops to
go back to 1997.
you know what 1997 was that's when the
soviet union basically fell apart and so
what he was saying is he wants no nato
troops in any of eastern and central
europe and also in the baltics he wants
to pull back on on the lafayette and
estonia
no that wasn't a peace gesture that was
a war gesture well and i i think you're
correct let's not forget that trump was
impeached because he threatened to
withhold federal aid from ukraine you're
correct about that well nobody knows
well we can go into that a separate
issue but we're going to confuse the uh
the conversation i think we should stick
on this and then we can talk about that
he did send federal uh lethal aid to
ukraine and and
again nobody's saying what vladimir
putin is doing is correct right if 44
million people want to be free they have
the right to be free but again i ask
where does this end up why is that our
responsibility i didn't say how does
this end i didn't say those are you what
you took objection to is me saying that
uh that ukraine it blunted in the first
month
the russian invasion by using the
citizen militia that's what i said well
that's what i said and what you didn't i
didn't get a chance to but now i'll give
you a chance to become relevant on your
comment to say
that what the west should have been
doing from that point
was facilitating what ukraine needed in
order to defend themselves because we
are committed to free of freedom and
democracy and you're talking about 44
million people who are dealing i'm not
saying we should have put troops in
there
i am saying we should have allowed the
air equipment to go in there now we are
why are we now allowing it to go in
there because
it
it's it's now apparent that ukraine can
use them and win
but back then we didn't want to get
drawn in why because putin was
threatening us like he's now threatening
us with nuclear weapons putin is a bully
bullies
push until they find a wall yeah putin's
got a problem
he can't win ukraine and he's not going
to be able to win ukraine because of the
ukrainian people if they're given the
tools they need to defend themselves the
polls understand this why are the polls
on the front line here because they know
if ukraine falls to
it becomes part of russia they're the
border
and they know what that means and hey
hey pat you're
doing a lot of listening right you're
probably processing everything and paul
thanks tyler getting in on it uh how are
you processing all this there's mus you
must i mean you've done a whole episode
on ukraine you've watched ukraine on
fire everything but there's there's a
difference between like
watching an episode of being right on
the inside and no matter how many papers
i read
you don't know until you're dealing
directly with yanukovych and you know
oligarchs and you're doing the point
you're there for a few years i think the
question would be the final one so
american military news comes out
yesterday two days ago russia warns
world war three very risk is very
significant so russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov warned on monday that the
risk of a third world war cannot be
underestimated and said the u.s and nato
are adding to the risk by supplying
weapons to ukraine lavrov said
russia agreed on the in the
admissibility of nuclear war and set
avoiding such conflict as our principal
position however
he warned that now the risks are very
significant he particularly criticized
the us for supplying man portable
anti-aircraft missile launchers and
anti-tank javelin missiles which he said
could be used for terrorist attacks so
is this just a threat or is this a bluff
or do you think things can get pretty
ugly
there you know what happens when you
compute capitulate to a bully
they keep moving
and you know this is it a threat yeah is
that sorry is it a serious threat
i don't know
um i know that they're they're losing
and they know that so they're getting
desperate and so they're making these
crazy uh
accus or threats
but
frankly
you know the moment we capitulate is the
moment the world becomes
more dangerous not less dangerous
because the bully understands where the
red line doesn't mean a red line anymore
and when they start getting away with a
nuclear threat then what happens in in
estonia when they when the russian
ethnic population in estonia that putin
is stirring up right now you know he he
what happens when he gets them to do
like what he did in eastern ukraine and
say they they're not having their
interests protected and russia's got to
go in there now and protect them well
no they're nato country
uh yeah so if if if moscow goes into
into
estonia i you know are we going to give
in
um and if we've given in on the nuclear
threat on ukraine
we'll give in on the nuclear threat in
estonia and all of a sudden the balkans
go back all of a sudden sweden and
finland are talking about maybe becoming
a part of nato why
because they feel threatened now
for years they've always said neutrality
we don't need to be a part of nato all
of a sudden they're changing germany i
mean like i mean this is one of those
big surprises to me yeah the the
chancellor of germany is a social
democrat which is the party that's
affiliated with putin's party you know
where you have these affiliations
internationally
uh and he's rearming germany
amazing i mean it's historic why because
now germany started this guy recognizes
his country is worried i mean he's got
his relationships with putin
but the country is worried that
germany's borders now are good good
potential we have should be worried that
should the world be worried if germany
starts arming itself i mean they don't
exactly have the best reputation
arms right but the point of getting that
is you've got all these things things
swirling around nothing is black and
white putin is causing all of the
swirling around uh and so when he starts
threatening us with doomsday
and we give in it's not going to get
better it's going to get worse let me
ask you we talked about him being a
bully
uh how different was his relationship
with trump versus biden
i was preoccupied during those things so
you know my understanding of is what you
saw uh in the papers as well i never
thought trump was pro-putin i think
trump's foreign policy
and it's
true and it was true in russia it was
true everywhere it was true in north
korea
was personal diplomacy he believed i
mean the donald trump i know
believes that when he can look you in
the face and he can talk to you you'll
understand his resolve and if you
understand his resolve that ability to
understand it will allow for things to
happen
uh you know from in
in in theory
moscow and putin he
there no russian invasions happened
anywhere during trump's presidency why
because i believe putin understood
trump wouldn't tolerate it
um
and
so
what they talked about i have no idea
but i do know
that just like north korea
would rabble rattled the sabres before
trump was president they went quiet
after after trump met with kim jong-un
trump's conversations with putin putin
went quiet
um and
uh and even china i mean i happen to
think if if trump had been reelected i
think they would have finished the uh
the international tariff negotiations
and then you'd have seen a new kind of
approach on foreign policy with xi
jinping
by trump because he would have fixed
what he thought was the first problem
and then he'd be dealing with the
political relationship all on a personal
basis um and so
i i don't know what trump and putin
talked about i just know the
the results of his presidency and the
results were very positive for
freedom-loving countries so before we
transition out from the story of ukraine
and the story of
russia putin
the story with you in the world of
lobbyists okay and that's the business
you've been in since 1980
you know when you got into the business
you know when they talk about you going
to jail what did you really go get
sentenced 47 months for some are saying
russia some are saying the 10 million
dollar loan from the oligarch some are
saying the 60 million dollars from
ukraine what was the real reason at the
end that you got 47 months there was no
10 million dollar loan from the
oligarchs there was no launch of
oligarchs there was a bank law that they
accused me of uh us bank um
what i was
villainized for was being pro putin you
know uh traitor to my country
um
you know what i was convicted of were
legal issues which i talked about in the
book uh that
that i'd already been cleared up on
or been cleared up on in in the fair
issues on the tax issues on the the f
bar which is the offshore accounts
issues and i'm not going to get into
them today but uh but in the book i get
into them in detail
um and you need to understand the
context and that was exactly what
weissman's strategy was was to confuse
the context to make me a villain in the
in the uh in the media and then get me
convicted on just over charging and just
dropping hundreds of thousands of
documents millions of pages and putting
me in solitary putting me in solitary so
i couldn't really prepare myself wise
mom being the right hand guy for mueller
right
weizmann ran at least my case he ran
they ran it but i think he ran the whole
special
what role did leticia leticia jackson
play the teaser james i'm sorry natasha
james play no
she's the attorney general in new york
but she was trying to go after trump you
know
god knows how many different things they
were trying to find they couldn't find
anything except for
you know the ceo you know who apparently
trump gave him
ferrari or something like that they
couldn't find anything else so i guess
the question for you would be to follow
from 1980
till you gone
uh uh again to 47 months
how often ford reagan all these guys you
work with how often were you a target
the way you were at target the moment
you started helping out trump
never no so you've never been a target
like the i don't know so why why this
level of hatred towards
targeting trump versus every everybody
else you supported was also republican
what's different between trump and
everyone else
the world has changed i mean number one
social media
uh uh number two i mean social media was
trump's uh
helped trump
facilitate trump's election
and it dominated social trump's
presidency
um you know we used to have
in the going back to four days there was
one new cycle and you got you used
between eight in the morning until about
three in the afternoon to get on the
three network news programs that night
uh and that that was the way you built
your your strategy for the day by the
time you know the second reagan second
term and jim baker mastered this we had
two cycles we had the morning cycle in
the afternoon cycle so that we dominated
was in the news in the evening and what
you saw in the papers in the morning um
today you have 24-hour cycle and
uh
you've also had journalism
mainstream journalism change
uh it used to be
that you know the fact checkers were the
most important part of any write any any
articles you read in the non-editorial
pages
fact checkers don't exist anymore
it's first to file not first to get the
facts
and and that's driven by the social
media to some respect and it's the
social media has you know the is
dominated
the mainstream medias because the
mainstream media how do they how do
these new reporters grow grown into
national celebrities
the articles they get they get they get
they get to be writing and also the the
coverage they get on the tv talk shows
and the clicks
how many clicks so that if their
articles get clicks they the more clicks
they get uh the more attention that
brings to them the more attention it
brings to them it's helped their
economics uh and
what gets clicks
news or or or i wonder why
i wanna i wanna say okay it's social
media but
nixon got targeted hardcore you know
when they were after him you know a lot
you know
we can give names of people of course
post media coming out first debate being
john f kennedy and nixon on tv where it
was no longer radio on radio nixon's
winning on tv is not but
the targeting has happened for a while
maybe not at the levels that we have
today right with intensity intensity so
but why do that's what i want to know
forget the social media side
why why specifically towards trump
well
again well i think the main reason for
trump and i get into this in the book
is because
he threatened the system
not democrats the system he was going to
drain the swamp the swamp wasn't the
democrats the swamp was washington the
swamp was new york the swamp was the
elites versus the people the to quote
hillary clinton the basket of
deplorables that's they were they were
coming coming not since andrew jackson
were where the people
coming to the streets of washington the
way they were under trump
really i mean you look at
all of the
the
changes the fdr uh
even abraham lincoln
you
you didn't have
an attack on the system the way you did
when trump or andrew jackson depending
on how you want to do it became
president and
so and and they weren't ready for it in
trump's case nobody was ready for trump
to be president except trump's
supporters and they were the quiet still
to quote nixon silent majority i mean
they were hoping uh i felt trump was
going to win the whole time
in 2016. i wrote a memo which they tried
and weissman tried to make into a uh
something it wasn't in on thursday
before the election in 2016 that i sent
to the president to jared and to write
writes previous who was running the rc
at the time
where i said
that trump is going to win onto him
tuesday
and i wrote the memo on thursday
specifically because i felt that there
was still time on the week before
for clinton to change if clinton has run
a smart last 10 days of the campaign she
could have won i'm not saying she would
have but she could have by thursday
it was too late she couldn't do in my
mind what had to be done in the states
where i thought nick or trump would win
so i wrote a memo that said
that it's really important this weekend
that we get out there and make people
understand we're going to win i said the
media's not going to believe it
in the memo
but we have to put the marker down
because when we do hit on this on
tuesday i said
they're going to no one's going to
understand how this happened and they're
going to try and say we stole the
election
uh and we didn't
uh
some of them some of what i asked for
they suggested it happened happened but
i'm not saying it was because of my memo
um
but my point was that the system wasn't
expecting rig uh
trump to win and so the combination of
he's going to drain the swamp nobody
expected him to be standing on wednesday
after the election
the people crying like schools teachers
unions closing schools because
yeah i mean
when did we ever have that happen when
did we ever have that happen uh but that
became the defining
atmosphere
for trump's presidency i guess what i'm
asking is the following by the way some
people may even say you know you
uh are part of the swamp as a lobbyist
you know i think lobbyists would you say
lobbyists have done a lot of damage i
think lobbyists well it depends on what
they do i mean lobbying is government
affairs what does i mean you walked into
an office of a congressman you think
they're the experts on all the topics
they're dealing with in the committees
no a good government affairs firm is
providing information for people to make
decisions now there's corruption within
the system what good does a lobbyist do
like if i were to say a you know what
what good does a cop do okay i can say
what good a cop does what good does a
military soldier do what good does a
whoever what good what good does all
right provide information factual
information on whatever the issues are
that they're representing uh in the case
of foreign government representing
foreign governments they facilitate
understanding because people they don't
they they don't
people don't talk the same to each other
they don't understand the same to each
other and a in a good lobbyist which has
become a
pejorative term
but a good lobbyist is somebody who
brings information finds out what the
problems are goes back and gets
responses to the problems and comes back
and
that's the mundane work that gets done
in the legislative process and the
regulatory process all the time
what you read about are the excesses
hunter biden going into the state
department and saying that uh we need to
keep we have we need to back off on
prosecutors uh in ukraine uh coming down
on barisma that's that's what lobbying
is viewed but that's not lobbying aren't
there that's political uh political
influence wouldn't you say lobbies are
like the ultimate spinners though like
they're the ultimate spinners they'll
spin any story into they'll use some
factual things and then they'll spin it
into whatever story or narrative they
want to tell but it is a form but
they're like the ultimate ultimate
spinners well
they that's one of the things they do
yes absolutely but again
don't deceive yourself
the system in washington is not meant
for congressmen to know everything and
their staffs know everything about all
the issues that they on the committees
they sit on they need information from
outside to make informed decisions
and good lobbyists provide that
information they
it's there's some of it is spinning
the congressman have to in the end make
judgments
isn't it all money driven meaning like
a lobbyist is gonna tell them that
information based on how much they're
getting paid by that company that repre
that they represent but the member of
congress understands that the lobbyist
is showing up on behalf of att
and so if that comes with a certain
frame of understanding um and the
information they're getting from at t
they get and they have to contextualize
that versus what they're getting from a
company that's opposing att you know
buying time warner or whatever the case
might be what would happen if lobbyists
were just completely eliminated
then you would have a lot of legislation
that was uninformed
but watch this though check this out so
about half of retiring
senators and a third of retiring house
members retire as lobbyists
but let's you know every you we've got
this image in our head of lobbies you
know who's the lobbyist who the teachers
union
okay teachers are the lobbyists i agree
so you're gonna take them out
no no one's talking to teachers you know
they're talking about taking a lobbying
company out but the teacher's unit is a
lobbyist
uh aarp is a lobbyist they're also
there's an element of them that's also
corrupt but my point is there's a role
they serve and when you start saying
take lobbyists out of the equation
you're taking everybody out of the way
who would win elections if there was no
lobbyists like let's just say it's it's
it's criminal
to hire a lobbyist or lobbyist firm
who who would that favor the most if all
of that was gone and out
i don't even know how you could do that
to start with but if
but if you're saying take
take
lobbyists out you're really i think what
you're saying is take the money out of
contributions sure if there's no money
there's no lobbying but again that means
the teachers union doesn't get to
contribute the afl cio doesn't get to
contribute i mean start and you think
they're going to give that up
no way i'm not saying they're going to
give it up by the way i actually don't
think it's going to happen not in my
lifetime i'm 43 it ain't going to happen
in my lifetime but all i'm asking is
you know if we did in everywhere who
does it hurt who does it benefit
look i i think
done correctly it hurts
good legislation
i mean if you i mean if you take out the
information flow that lobbying companies
that you
bring to the system
how does a member of congress
get their information where are they
going to get it
they're not they're not going to
intuitively know the technicalities of
big tech in the
exemptions that they have
as
from from publishing they're not going
to totally know that a friend of mine
was a was a lobbyist and a very high
paid lobbyist he made very good money
okay very very good money
and he left and got into a completely
different industry i said so why did you
get into a
you can make a lot of money i made a lot
of money i said okay this whole thing
about you know politics is dirty and all
this stuff he says listen
some of the stuff i did as a lobbyist it
eventually got to a point where i'm like
holy [ __ ] if i continue like this this
thing's eventually going to catch up to
me with what we're doing with our team
how
how ugly is the world of lobbying
meaning the power plays
is is it
you know how okay we ask this question
regularly we you know hey if you want to
build a championship in football what
matters the most the gm the owner the
quarterback the running back the defense
all the stuff you go through offensive
coordinator recruit who do you put up
there right
if we want somebody to win okay if we
want somebody to do into a candidate to
win
how important of a role does a lobbyist
play to help that person win how
important of a role does a lobbyist play
to get an amazon who moves a part of
their headquarters closer to you know
virginia or dc to pass some laws how
important of a role do lobbyists place
to pass some of these laws for them
well those are two different things
getting elected versus government both
of them yeah getting elected
you know money is important
but the money comes from a lot of
sources not just lobbyists so i i would
not make lobbying as the distinction
i mean
they're probably people and republicans
probably feel like they're outmanned in
getting uh by the democrats and getting
lobbyist money if you look at lobbyist
money most of it goes to democrats a lot
of it does
um but i don't think that matters to
getting elected i think what matters
getting elected is the your issue agenda
and then as an incumbent what you've
done
at the end of the day the american
people usually figure things out i'm a
big believer in our system
uh they usually figure things out they
can be fooled for an election cycle
um
but they they generally figure things
out and so lobbying to me is more
impactful in governance not in elections
money's going to come from somewhere
regardless you take lobbying money out
it's still going to come from somewhere
and so getting elected is a different
paradigm from my standpoint
as far as governing is concerned
lobbying plays a constructive role
if you you frame things correctly it's
still going to be up to the member to
make a decision
on the information that he gets um and
it's not like it's happening in a vacuum
a lobbying you get lobbyists on both
sides of issues more oftentimes than
multiple sides of issues
and so yes that puts
a a responsibility on the member to
understand the facts but that's part of
his job is to understand the facts you
got to make sure he gets the facts and
if he's getting both sides of the facts
he's got enough to make judgments
i would you know
make the point that special interests
are not particularly necessarily
lobbyists that control members of
congress but industries
and
how do you get i mean and that's part of
if you come from a coal mining area coal
mining industry is going to have an
impact on the members of congress from
that area
is that wrong
probably not because that's the area
they're from and they need to understand
those issues
it's where
where i have my problem with washington
and where i think trump tapped into
something in 2016
was where members of congress will be
for something when they're in power
and then when they lose power they're
against what they were for
on on an issue
and and that hypocrisy
gets is what gets lo gets give an
example
obama or trump um well i mean neither in
that sense i'm talking more
congressional i mean i'll give you an
example it's a political it's a
political one but it's nonetheless the
filibuster in the senate
how many you've seen all the eclipse
schumer and the democrats being against
the filibuster being removed when they
had the when they were in the minority
in the senate and now they're for the
filibuster being
[Music]
getting rid of it why because it
enhances their power so it's the
equation is defined by what it does for
power not what it does for democracy uh
mcconnell's done the same thing same
thing on both sides
and uh
trump campaigned against both of them
he they were the swan can't stand trump
yeah well
but the point is why doesn't trump like
mcconnell
because mcconnell to trump is the same
thing as schumer is the trump as far as
he's just a swamp creature it's a swamp
creature why doesn't mcconnell like
trump because mcconnell is a swamp
creature and trump wants to get rid of
this disrupter yeah and so
will they ever see i i mean trump no i
was there's no hope for reconciliation
well no there's always hope for
reconciliation because there'll be
mutuality of interest
will they ever like each other no
but will they ever work together yeah i
think they would hey pat
it would seem tell me if i'm wrong here
we're talking about lobbyists back to
that
paul's
almost defending lobbyists i would say
that
you would i mean as a lobbyist hello i
mean a political consultant as well you
would think that there's a role that
there's a role and that they are a net
positive to governance whereas pat
correct me if i'm wrong at the end of
the day you think lobbyists are a net
negative to america am i wrong on that
okay so here's how i see it okay
you know the whole conversation between
sales and marketing yep
what sales what's marketing right
marketing spreads sales is
one-dimensional marketing is like a
story
goes out like coca-cola share a coke
with
jose with adam oh my god i don't even
drink coke but hey i got this great
campaign came out of australia coke took
off they become what they become right
i think
lobbyists are the ultimate cmos
they'll do laps around cmos at major
corporations like if a major corporation
wants to hire a real good cmo go
freaking put on an ad and say i'm
looking for former lobbyists who help
somebody win i'll give you a congressman
that would have i would tell you like he
would make one hell of a cmo at a major
core and i'm being very frank with you i
mean very soon because
the strategy they take with research and
data and gathering them and telling the
story and saying it in a way where
you're like man this thing makes sense
it's a very powerful job
but ah it's the ultimate spin zone
though it's the ultimate spins in my
opinion i may be wrong and by the way
let's just say one day you get into
politics if the other guy's using
lobbyists guess what we got to get for
you we got to get some solid lobbyists
on you because if you're going to use it
i have to use it you know what i'm
saying i'm not going to do it but hey
you're going to use oh we're going to
become these noble people we're not
going to use it no you have to so he
makes the point about so what do you
want to do teachers union should we get
rid of them i mean if both sides are
going to use it you have to use it okay
that that's the part where once you get
into that game
that [ __ ] is dirty and you you wanna
you're gonna play that game against me
watch how better of a job i'm gonna
maneuver against you and
you may disagree with me but that's my
assessment on the world of lobby look i
i mean i understand the point and and by
the way donald trump would agree with a
lot of what you just said um
but uh but the point is
what are you gonna replace it with
i mean if you can't expect congress
especially in today's day and age to be
experts on all the things they have to
be experts on and you can't they they
there's not enough staff for them the
money for the staff they would need to
have an expert on this an expert on this
an this
etc so you have to have a role yeah how
you frame the
role to protect the concerns that you
have that's a different issue but the
the to say that throw the baby in the
bath water out
that's not that it's not realistic
uh and it frankly i think is harmful to
the system i i disagree with a lot of
what the teachers union stand for as far
as what they think they can do with the
with our kids in school but i see a role
for them and they're massive bullies
though
they're massive bullies because they
have the power to be a massive amount
yeah so that but but again it goes back
because we've empowered them i think in
1870 i don't know what the year was when
they were trying to eliminate lobbies
and create laws and all this stuff so
it's been going on for a while where you
know they knew this was eventually
because some of these guys were going to
become more powerful than actual
presidents congressmen and senators some
lobbies are more powerful than you know
jim baker you you've read his book i'm
sure you've read it if you haven't read
this book i couldn't put the book down
by the way some of the stuff he was
talking about in there on the stories of
what happened you know jim baker is more
powerful than most of these guys that
became president jim he could have
become a president but he chose to play
a different role you know yeah i think
again i think i think lobbyists uh you
know in a big way make the political
world well you know what you know i just
thought of it with first lobbyists
because you you at one point said well
they represent industries abuse by the
way you said industries lobbyists
represent industry we met initially at
an insurance conference yeah now 10
years ago
that's probably the biggest brokerage uh
industry meeting there's another one
called
aalu you're probably familiar with that
yes
they've changed their name since then
but it's the insurance
advocacy group in dc every year the
meeting is in dc we're in the insurance
business financial services business the
whole point of that meeting is to get
all the insurance people to dc
to do our meeting and then what do they
all do go to the hill to meet with our
congressmen to basically
uh
promote
the importance of insurance and you know
financial wellness in the family so
there is
there is an upside you know even to us
but but but the reason why they need
that because on the other side elizabeth
warren's got the best of the best was
lobbying against hurting people in the
financial industry so you have to have
the counter attack that's one example my
point earlier right if you're going to
use it i have to hire this lobbyist and
that's what he's saying is that like you
can't touch the baby with the bath water
i think
i don't disagree with you
and and you know and yes there are
excesses yeah
um
again part of my biggest problem
with and why i think why i believe that
trump was going to win in 2016 was
because
you washington becomes
segmented segregate segregated and they
focus on what's in their interests and
not in the people whose interests are
they are representing meaning the
american people
and it bothers me and i got out of
american politics until for about eight
years when i was over in ukraine because
i was fed up
with being part of a system where when
people got elected and came to
washington
they didn't worry about
their promises as much as they worried
about building a power base inside
washington i know it's true of
republicans and democrats
and and the hypocrisy that i said a
minute ago using the filibuster example
but that is true throughout on issues
and on uh it's it's power based and that
bothered me and did i think i could
change the system no i couldn't change
this i said okay come on paul you could
have done it well i did and actually
because i then changed my mind in 2016
when i saw somebody who could do it
and and i got back in the game um
and
do you regret it no not at all no do you
think when you wrote that
article thursday of 2016 right before
tuesday saying this guy's going to win
it do you feel that way about him in
2024 that trump is going to win it
because i don't think desantis is going
to run i don't think desantis wants to
be on the same stage with trump because
it's going to get ugly
oh i don't think desantis runs if trump
runs i agree i think if trump runs
it freezes the field i mean there'll be
somebody whether it's
bill weld again or uh you know
hogan uh uh or k or kasich somebody will
run
it won't matter trump will trouble
dominate the republican primary on the
republican primary side uh what are the
chances he runs 100 well i think biden
is making it easier every day well
buying won't be running against nobody
24. we all know that but
you got to look at what you got now we
have to project what's 2024 going to
look like well we have to look at it
through the prism of two things
the biden administration and the 2022
elections the biden administration has
failed on all of the key issues that
trump was succeeding on
and to the point where
i couldn't believe this
there's a i mean i i think the poll is
an outlier poll 19
of the people who voted for him want him
to run again in
2024. now think about that for a minute
but i did the yeah biden got 80 million
votes 19 percent of biden
right you want him to 16 million out of
the eight that's my point do the math
that's embarrassing
who gave that number what i harris's
poll i think it was mark penn's poll why
is that number shocking though eighty in
one and a half years he's
60 million people that voted for him
they weren't voting for him paul you
know that but they were voting against
trump you know this well some of them
were but my point is nobody's like hell
yeah but joe's my guy they said donald
trump's not my guy and i'll take anyone
else well we can get into that in a
minute but the point is still to me
that's shocking and
pat picked it up 60 million people who
voted for him within a year have said
i don't want him to run again
that's an incredible number uh and
but it but you but now get underneath
the numbers what does it mean
young people why do you think they're
talking about you know student debt
again because young people when they i
think there's like 60 of his vote in
2020
you know he's down in the 30s 33 percent
of young people said they would vote for
him if they show up
so you've got an issue on turnout and
then you got to show up of who turns out
he's not going to you know third a third
is going to vote for him you look at
hispanics
this was a movement that was starting in
2016. it was already starting
to move on cultural issues and on the
economy those are the things that are
important to latino in the latino
community
[Music]
trump accelerated that a little bit
and biden in one year as president is
accelerating even more for republicans
to the point that we could republicans
could carry a majority of the hispanic
vote
uh in
2024 yeah
it's a layup to well
that's why it's a that's why it looks
like a layup for 2022. um and what does
that mean well that means that these
developing uh
segments of the voting population
are moving away from their traditional
place and once it starts to move it
doesn't just come back and
what's going to happen as a result of
that in 2023 23 what will happen to my
judgment is the republicans are going to
win both houses of congress more
importantly is what happens in the house
the plurality in the house of the
democratic caucus is going to be the
left
it's going to be the aoc types um maybe
not the leadership but the plurality
the elizabeth warrens on the senate side
are going to be empowered as well so
that the left is going to have more of a
stranglehold on washington
than they do today
in 23. what does that mean for
republicans in 24 and to your question
about trump
the agenda is going to be way out of
here over here when the american people
are here yeah and the and the and the
governance is making it worse i mean how
does the vocal not realize that because
they don't care about it
what they care about is getting power
they understand the left understands a
very basic thing
first you take power then you create
change
they have to take power first
being the big fish in a small pond is
how they take power then they'll worry
about it because at the end of the day
what is american politics it's it's two
people you generally running for
president you get one of the two people
nominated you got a chance to take over
the white house joe biden is the best
example of that um and and so from the
left standpoint they're playing the long
game
and uh and they see the opportunity
to take control of the democratic party
in washington in 23
and and then
worry about 24 next elizabeth warren you
know she's already running for president
uh and she's gonna you know she'll
change her strokes here and there but
first she's got to consolidate she
doesn't stand the chance well elizabeth
warren
you know she's not marketable again
again nominations are a different game
oh nomination yeah but if she gets
nominated she's got a chance i'm not
saying she hasn't that ship all sailed
the elizabeth
the bernies
like we've been there done that 2016
2020 they're out here but no we haven't
go
i totally disagree with you i totally
disagree with you 2016 was the i mean
2020 was the wrong time bernie sanders
when we put the strategy together for
for uh trump in 2016
part of the vote that he got and we
targeted it was sanders vote in the
primaries because they weren't leftist
they were
drain the swamp type of people
and
what's going to happen is the rhetoric
of 2024
is going to be revolutionary on the from
the west
from the left standpoint
and again if they can consolidate and
get it in the primaries because in the
private you get through the primaries
the left the democratic primaries are
going to be primaries of the left
not the moderate democrats not the joe
manchins not the joe bidens the joe i
mean
biden emerged from for very uh
specific reasons i always feared joe
biden
i mean he was the one who in fact i did
a couple things you might be the only
person in america no fears joe biden
what feared him in 2020 feared him why
because i thought he could win why
because american presidential politics
when you have an incumbent running for
reelection so it's not an open seat
it's it's a matter of contrast
well you you said it a minute ago people
were voting against trump right why were
they voting against trump his
personality correct uncle joe
uncle joe hide him in the club hide him
in the basement you know create this
image of this you know soft gentle
person uh that's the right image
throw kovit on top of that throw
expansion of voting on top of that throw
uh everything else he gets a chance and
he pulled it off
should he have won no but he did
for that reason so from the left
standpoint
they think they're smarter than that
and
yet joe won
so we get control of the democratic
party we'll figure out how to win the
general election against whoever if it's
trump we're going to go add him hard on
trump and and they'll make his
personality they'll try to make that the
issue
and sneak by
with softening elizabeth warren or
softening uh
who you know
buddha judge
um and then figure it out later after
they went you think a wild card like a
rock celebrity like if there's ever been
a time to come in and win like this is a
good time to do it one of these guys
that's got a couple hundred million
followers on instagram twitter they come
and use that card i think elon musk in
the future is a candidate for president
he's not born here though uh-huh born in
southwest that's true actually you're
right that's that is the restriction
you're right but but that he's going to
be a major player well he is now but i
mean
um but in our political system
you're saying an outsider with a major
massive following and a ton of money
like a mark cuban will he run in in 2024
like impossible he'd like to be
president
he saw trump do it he's a democrat uh
you know he's got a social image that
he's building uh could he win the
nomination i don't think so i think the
problem on the democratic side is it's
going to be a leftist candidate for
president and wow
and i'm going to come that will we're
going to have a leftist candidate i
think that's what's going to emerge from
the democratic party especially if what
happens in 22 it's going to hurt them
they're going to get trounced that
that's the direction
look at what they're doing they're
doubling down i'm moving left i'm
putting pressure on biden right now on
student debt
soon if he does student debt
i mean it's it's i mean it's really
stupid from a political standpoint but
from the left standpoint uh you know
they like what it stands for but if he
does the student debt issue what's going
to happen
he's not going to get he's not going to
pump up turn up
in an off-year cycle among young people
i mean he may go from 37 to 45
voting for democrats but you know what
the number one issue is for for people
in 19 18 to 29 right now
inflation
the economy
and jobs and so
do you think
that forgiving the debt for a segment of
the 18 to 29 because what happens all
the people aren't going to college right
what happens to people who are starting
college next year
what about my debt
you know these are the kinds of issues
that you know
affect who's going to turn out and how
they're going to turn out what about the
guys who paid for their debt yeah like
me i paid off my okay there you go i
mean the point is the left doesn't care
that's a big that's a big vote uh if
you're able to get you know all these
folks college debt to be
forgiven you know what loyalty you'll
get from them because that that keeps a
lot of people but they're not even a
majority of the segment of the 18 to 20.
not at all they're not no and what
what's going to happen what does it do
to inflation
which is the number one issue for that
voter block well actually for every
voter block but for that voter bloc you
know it's going to make it worse
and so all of a sudden now you're
you're rewarding people who a small
segment who got college debt
and you're punishing
everyone in that time in the country
with inflation which is the number one
issue
the but the left only cares about where
they're gonna be in uh january of 2023.
are you in trump in communication right
now you guys stopping
i'm not going to get into that kind of
conversation the only reason i ask the
question is because
if if he does go 2023
okay 2024 and he runs
um
who's he going to put on his campaign
who's he going to bring in who's out
there that he can bring into alma mate
there's not i don't think he'll have any
trouble hiring people
i i i mean i
i saw thiel is making a decision to you
know thiel is a peter thiel that's a
pretty big name to have there but that's
a different role that's more of the
truth yeah yeah no but i i don't think
trump will have any trouble putting
together a campaign if he decides to run
and it'll be a campaign that's more
pro-trump
i mean in the sense that
one of trump's biggest problems when he
first became president when he was first
elected
is he didn't have a bench
he didn't have people to put into the
government
um yeah he had trump didn't know anybody
in washington when he ran for president
i mean i mean
i tell the story of the book i mean when
i got involved normally when you get
involved in a campaign after you're
somewhere in the middle of the process
and you have a specific role you have to
come in you have to clean out some stuff
move people outside bring your own
people in
i had none of that problem because there
was nobody to move out
there was no there there
trump was the campaign
he was the candidate he was the pollster
he was the communication director he was
the uh the speechwriter he was he was
the uh
advanced guy i mean he you know i mean
and there were a couple of people who
were the gophers to that gophers
assistants to do things hope was very
important for trump because i think so i
hope
you know he was a very organized person
she understood trump and so she could
get done what trump asked her to do
efficiently and quickly which is why he
loved her
[Music]
but i'm talking about
but but trump came up with the strategy
of
hope do this let's put this tweet on
whatever he was the strategist of the
campaign and the in the media guy as
well what was your role
well when i came in i first came in to
help because of that
that kind of campaign structure
the the nomination process
is
a multiple process a multi-faceted
process
you have to win the primaries but you
have to win the delegates
and they're not connected they ca
there's there is a dotted line
connection
but for example
cruz understood
all the rules of the republican party in
the nominating process
and so
the feeling was trump's strategy was i'm
one of 16 people i can get nominated by
just building my pluralities after each
election
cruz's strategy was there are 16 people
against trump
and so
the the
opportunity to elect delegates that are
not automate that are not
automatically elected it creates an
opportunity to have a convention floor
of non-trump people meaning
let's say in every state was different
but let's say uh
you know in
virginia elects
well
yeah elects their delegates at a
convention but they have a primary and
there's uh some some
the allocations are
bike cd and by at large
but the conventions elect the delegates
so
let's say i've won i don't know i think
virginia has 51 delegates but
i've won 37 delegates based on the on
the law
but i don't control the convention i
could have 10 delegates on the floor
10 delegates on the floor if there's a
majority of people who are not for trump
on the floor
even though trump's got 40 percent 45
percent of the convention
they can vote they have to vote for
trump based on this get in the states
the first ballot but they can vote
against trump on rules on
freeing up delegates and undercutting
state laws on convention uh officers on
the platform and then on the second
ballot if they keep it from happening on
the first ballot
the ones who were voting for trump in
many cases are freed to do whatever they
want and if they're not trump people but
they were just trump but trump uh
bodies or not trump bodies
the the nomination is at risk which was
the crew strategy that was cruz's
strategy he had people who understood
convention politics very well and party
rules very well
so trump sees himself all of a sudden
winning primaries
and then subsequent state conventions
electing
cruz delegates
who have to vote for trump for the first
ballot but only for trump on the ballot
question
and he's saying
this is fixed it's it's i'm being
being robbed the party is cheating me
well the party wasn't cheating him
uh he just didn't have a structure that
was paying attention to the rules so
that way he was running the campaign he
came into his state he wins the state he
then moves there's no that almost cost
him well that's why he brought me in
that's why he brought me in because when
he moved there was nobody left in the
state well guess what cruz people were
going in after the primaries uh and they
were electing the bodies to be at the
convention and so
trump finally had a meeting with priebus
and to complain
that the party is screwing me
and priebus said to him no donald you
just don't understand the rules you just
don't understand the rules i remember
that and
so trump turned to lewandowski who was
sitting with him there said did you know
this corey of course no because corey
never done anything like this he didn't
understand the rules
and so trump's realizing i'm winning
but i'm not winning
and
that's my expertise
among other things and that's why i was
brought in what happened to roger stone
what happened he seems like he's like
turning more and more against uh this is
your former business partner what's
going on with him and trump oh they just
have a love i mean there was like big
brother little brother i mean
going back to the 1980s i mean rogers
trump became president because of roger
stone not in the sense that roger
elected
trump but roger was the one who set in
trump's mind you can be president
and when trump started to finally look
at
washington because he again the only
time he never when i brought him to
washington in the spring of 2016 he
didn't know it basically didn't know
anybody unless they had come to new york
to ask him for money
and he knew just as many on the
democratic side as other republicans he
said
right right and so
so nobody knew trump
but roger neutral and and
roger got trump to start paying
attention to politics in like 1983 and
84. and then and i go into this in
detail as well then ross perot ran for
president
in in 92
and trump looked at the pearl thing and
said well it's an interesting phenomenon
and then of course
ross
pearl loses but trump says
i'm smarter than these guys
i mean i i wouldn't he did only stupid
things he could have been president and
there was a chance that the time point
that perrault was leading uh or close to
leading in the in the three-party race
1921 you know he was hovering right but
but bush was at 36 and clinton was about
35 36 and there was a lot of undecided
um
it was a three it was just parole was
clinton's best campaign manager well he
was in the he was in the end but trump's
point was ross perot could have been
elected yeah
yeah but he wasn't smart enough and he
wasn't ready enough and he wasn't tall
enough he wasn't tall
that's another theory of rogers the guy
the guy with the big head and the winds
but
but
but roger was sort of the adrenaline to
that
with trump uh you said big brother
little brother you're comparing roger
stone as the big brother to trump being
the little brother no i think
it's changed
but at the time
at the time roger was the expert and
trump was the was trying to learn trump
never looked at himself as a little
brother but the point is
they would fight like that i mean they
loved each other they hated each other
and stone was your full-on business
partner well yeah yeah
for the in the 80s um
when we sold the firm in 92 uh i left
the fur after my lockup and roger went
off in a different direction too did you
get a nixon tattoo like him no i did not
[Laughter]
although nixon used to roger
my office was nixon's office when he
came to washington because i had the big
office of the roger convinced nixon paul
do you have any tattoos
if you had to get a tattoo of a
president if you had to
who would it be
george washington
boom right there and you're back father
of the country there you go okay so not
trump
i would never get a tattoo but if i had
to have a symbol of something i'd have
the father of my country
um and then maybe abraham lincoln after
that um but uh
but trump
and roger
you know have they're falling out trump
has never oh roger's always been there
somewhere in in trump's world
um and their fallouts are more just
because they're both media people media
stories and but not really behind the
scenes realities
tyler do you have that story about
voting kirsten i'll get the final
thoughts before we wrap up
the voting story that they want to get
100 of people to vote if you don't it's
a 20 fine did you hear about that or no
what's that that they're trying to
legislate
where
a hundred percent of people who are able
to vote have to vote or else there's
going to be a twenty dollar fine have
you heard any of this i have but that is
that's uh who's who's they
uh do you have this uh tyler is this a
minneapolis
let me tell you if the republican
offered that they'd be called racist
because who who's going to suffer from
that
the blacks and the minority communities
if there's a 20
you know poll tax penalty
uh
yeah so it's it's a crazy idea
can you find it or no yeah okay look
forward i'm gonna go to the kevin
mccarthy story tucker carlson said
uh declares kevin mccarthy a puppet of
the democratic party who shouldn't be
speaker sounds like an msnbc
contributor carlson pointed to an expert
excerpt in a forthcoming book this will
not pass by
new york times reporters alexander burns
and jonathan martin four days after the
january six insurrection capital right
they quote mccarthy as amusing allowed
whether twitter would ban
incidiary accounts that have tweeted
favorably
about the incident he was participating
in a meeting of the house of gop
leadership at the time congressman kevin
mccarthy of california told his close
friends liz cheney that he hoped the
social media companies would censor more
conservative republicans in congress he
stated donald trump the sitting
president had already been silenced by
those companies but mccarthy wanted the
tech oligarchs to do more and force
disobedient lawmakers off the internet
what are your thoughts on kevin mccarthy
i mean there's a lot of emotion goes
into that time frame and what people
were saying i don't know what mccarthy
said i've heard the tape as well but i
don't know the context do i think trump
and mccarthy have settled that whatever
the differences are yeah i do i mean
this the story is out today
but the
but the this this this leaked out a
while ago
and uh and
i've watched what mccarthy has said
since that time i've watched what trump
has not said since that time and it
appears to me that they've made their
piece on it
ask them a good question sure so paul
manafort he's in the house i mean
i didn't just realize that but what i'm
learning about you is uh there's a lot
more to you prior to than when everyone
really full-on knew your name in 2016.
okay so i'm looking at your essentially
your wikipedia page right here
um my question to you is two-part
question is number one how important is
your reputation to you
my reputation is important to me i'm
writing the book to sort of at least
have an historical record yeah i mean i
realized in the in the moment in 2017
and 18 there was a tsunami against me
and there was no way
me trying to put out anything
was possible plus once i got indicted
they put a gag order on me right so that
i couldn't say a thing even though all
the stories continue to leak and
and characterize me so your reputation
is important to you is what i'm
establishing so it says here in the book
it says um it's no exaggeration that
everything most americans think they
know about paul manafort is false so i'm
looking at again your wikipedia here
essentially nothing is black and white a
lot of gray so you know essentially
there's words at the beginning
power broker political advocate
political consultant political expert
right and then you kind of keep reading
down
and then it says criminal tax fraudster
money launderer scandal so you have all
these things you know for and against
you so my essential question is
who actually is paul manafort
paul manafort is an american
who has spent his life trying to improve
the political system and
bring democracy into countries around
the world paul manafort has always been
somebody who works with the united
states government's interest overseas
that includes whether they're
republicans or democrats in washington
uh because overseas
i grew up with there's you know politics
stops at the american border and
and i spent my life doing that
the paul manafort of 2017-18
is not paul manafort
it's a lie
it was part of a social media
uh uh orchestration to define me so that
i i i could
and i get into this in the book so that
i would feel the pressure and give in to
the system and give them up donald trump
which i wouldn't do one because there
was nothing to give up but two because
uh
uh you know i wasn't gonna lie
and and because i wouldn't lie
and because i wouldn't uh
concede to what was i considered to be
a a cabal against me
the uh i went to jail and i suffered in
the parts of that wikipedia that you're
reading were written by people who were
some of them were paid to stand outside
the courtroom holding signs traitor go
back to russia pro-putin things that i
spent my whole life in politics fighting
was now being being used to define me
when i couldn't speak back in the book
i get to speak back it's coming out in
august i'm looking forward to it i'll be
willing to come back here and talk to
you in the more of the details of it
when that when it does come out
because i'm not afraid of talking about
my life
i'm not afraid my life is something that
i'm proud of
and and
my book talks about why that is my
father became a republican on a matter
of principle the only republican in his
family he was he was elected as the
working man's mayor it was a blue-collar
tower three times new britain was a new
blue-collar town you know you know
stanley works had their first cut that's
where their headquarters still is uh
after ball bearings uh all these there's
an ethnic melting pot and irish italian
ukrainians armenians uh
and i grew up where you know you you
lived by you played sports you went to
school you live by your brains and you
chose your careers by your interest and
that's the american dream
and i lived it my father
my family company is a good example of
that
which i chose not to get involved in in
the end but my grandfather in 1919 with
10 years old came over to from italy
sent over by himself had to be picked up
in new york
and he created in 19 i mean he kept
moving before 1990 but in 1919 he
created with one pickaxe on the shovel
uh a demolition company that would with
one employee they went they would take
down buildings and the salvage was what
they made their money on uh
we're in the fifth generation of the
family business now it's one of the
largest
uh uh nuclear nuclear plant uh dec
i guess
it's not demolishing but to deconstruct
it uh worldwide uh it's
and
it's i think the biggest family-owned
business in connecticut now um
they live the american dream too each
generation that uh of my family and
one of the reasons i felt donald trump
could win in 2016 is my cousins are not
i'm not political they're businessmen
and many of them still haven't gone to
college i mean they they're they're the
fifth generation is but uh the fourth
generation but they they were the fabric
of our country
and they were all for donald trump and
they were calling me saying what do you
know about donald trump
they never called me in my political
career asked me about a candidate around
for president it was a signal to me what
i already felt but it was confirmation
that trump was onto something
uh that when you got out of washington
uh was existed in the country
ronald reagan understood the united
states very well he understood it
because when he was the spokesman for ge
and the and their weekly television
program uh he would travel to all the ge
plants around the country which were not
in the main the capital getting they
paid a million to do that eventually
they fired him because they said you're
talking too much about america but the
point is he was not going to the
capitals yeah because the plants were in
the secondary cities and in suburbs but
he got to understand the country and the
reason he was such and i think some of
my treasured moments when when i
traveled with him the reason he was so
confident what he was talking about was
because what he had learned about the
american people powerful donald trump
was the same way
donald trump threw the apprentice
different with the same kind of
connections made those connections with
the american people
and and i saw it firsthand when i would
travel with trump just like i saw it
firsthand with reagan well that's who i
am i'm that kind of that person and i
came to washington to help re to make a
career i'm representing that mo that
that
and to try and protect it
that's not in the wikipedia because the
wikipedia is a political document that's
written by the twitter types who spent
all the time trying to define i'll admit
i wasn't a fan of paul manafort in 2016
2017. straight up yeah i don't i'm now
officially a fan well thank you very
much i wouldn't have expected you to be
but i'm glad you are now thank you paul
are you a movie guy
i am favorite movie of all time
i'm assuming it's number two
is it godfather two or no
you know
you're one of my favorite of all time
godfather's up in the top five but
there's a there's a movie that i really
like a lot it's a silly movie it's
called michael
and michael is in the movie john
travolta is an angel who comes down
incredible movie yeah and it's a but
it's a movie about hope yeah and about
uh dreams crazy and that's why that is
my favorite never guess you're gonna say
michael i mean most people don't even
know the movie michael they probably
don't but to me
that is my favorite movie of all time
why did you think godfather too no first
of all
you know
first of all you have if you have any
interest of politics yeah
you you have to you
you have to because
it's all power plays that's all it is
and if to be able to survive the power
plays of the like what you're doing in
there
that's not easy especially for four
decades that's a pretty hard thing to do
but i'm gonna compliment you i would not
expect of you to know michael it's a
great movie he's a great boy yeah i'm
good
but do you think they'll ever change the
laws for a guy like elon musk to be able
to run like allah to say they're not
going to change that's not going to
happen yeah
last night if so it opens up a pbd yeah
no i'm a king maker i want to i want to
help the guy get there speed run i'll
give you a name give me one word that
comes to your mind steve bannon
[Music]
[Laughter]
idiot okay corey londowski
small man
hope hicks
good person
roger stone
good friend kellyanne conway
good friend mike pence
uh a very good vice president
desantis
uh the potential future
mueller
uh a man who's passed
one word
not a good person there's not one word
but mueller was used
and
in my book i talk about my experience
with him
i was not impressed with him hillary
clinton
fake
biden
uh
[Music]
over beyond this time the fbi
uh
i don't want to define all of their
people abuse their power avenatti
uh
charlotte
cohen michael cohen
uh overset podesta
which one
uh
the one you worked with good guy okay
uh john durham
uh
hope
last but not least donald trump
uh
a man who made a difference
fantastic awesome it's been a blast
having you on seriously this was great
thank you so much i'm looking forward to
having you back on when the book comes
out uh tyler put the link below for the
link of the book i'll give you the final
thoughts any final thoughts you want to
share with the audience before we wrap
up
well i mean i mean i appreciated this
opportunity today uh in this expanded
format allowed me the opportunity to get
into the context which i couldn't and i
would just like the american people to
pay attention to what i say not what
other people say about me fair enough
when's the book coming out on the 16th
august 6th but it's on it's pre-sales
now yeah we're going to put the link
below in chat box and the description
all of it for people to get it uh folks
we are not doing a podcast until next
tuesday i believe do we have two uh
monday we have william roger reeves the
uh the pilot for escobar very
interesting
william roger reeves on monday fantastic
folks have a great weekend we'll see you
next week take care bye bye bye
just kind of goes time goes so weird how
this thing works
victoria would you mind